[Music]
we're about to celebrate our 10th
anniversary of Android
welcome to developing Android apps in
Kotlin Android studio 3.1 is now
available for download or update in the
stable channel we're introducing Android
jetpack our next generation of
components and tools along with
architecture guidance designed to help
you accelerate your Android development
with the launch of jetpack and the KTX
cypress we've made Android development
even sweeter in color we've introduced a
new publishing format called the Android
app bundle well today we're announcing
Android P Beta Android P beta is
available on Google pixel and seven more
manufacturer flagship devices today
[Music]
we're about to see a hold use
form-factor idea from Android device
makers foldables so the screen can
literally Bend and fold developers
influenced the platform you're not on
top of it you're a part of what we do we
heard you wanted me more so we're
building more I'm only excited for the
release of Android studio 323 bringing
important features and more coming in
I am excited for next year where we're
going to continue to make content for
the next generation of Android dev I'm
happy to see a steady uptick of Kotlin
adoption and Android apps architecture
components in combination with cotton
that's what brought Michael to the next
level